i mean think about it we we just uh
celebrated
uh martin luther king's birthday a man
who
who is associated with color blindness
um judge me by the content of my
character not
uh the color of my skin that is what the
civil rights movement used to be about
today the civil rights movement is about
black
lives matter not all lives
black lives say it or i'm coming after
you
we've turned the king sensibility on its
head
i mean that's where we are as a country
and that's where the left is
as a country and i don't think that joe
biden feels he can
he can oppose that and succeed
politically
in the democratic party so i think he's
doing
what he feels he needs to do he needed a
he needed a black woman
as a running mate so he found a black
woman to run
um and i think he's checking off the
boxes
in terms of race and gender and sexual
orientation
right down the list because that is what
today's left demands
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
senior fellow at the manhattan institute
a wall street
journal columnist and author of the
upcoming book
maverick a biography of thomas soule
jason reilly welcome to the reuben
report
thanks for having me i am glad to have
you here i thought this would be
the right week to have you on uh not
only because the doc is coming out
uh but obviously monday was mlk day
there's a lot going on in the world
and i've been following what you do and
what the manhattan institute does
for quite some time so i'm looking
forward to the chat for the people that
don't have any idea who we are who who
is jason reilly and why
is he on the reuben report
well uh i'm a journalist uh i've been uh
affiliated with the wall street journal
for about a quarter century now
and um i write a political column for
them a weekly column mostly about uh
urban
issues uh crime uh immigration race uh
economics and so forth and
um uh and i'm also like you a big fan
of thomas soule uh and i've written a
few books over the years and my most
recent one
is a biography of thomas sol which is
being published right around the same
time
that uh a documentary film on his life
that i narrate
is also being uh being released yeah so
the book is coming out actually on may
25th and we'll put the pre-order link
below the doc is actually coming out
this weekend
on some uh public tv stations and then
and then streaming services and all that
good stuff and obviously
uh you know i know that you know how
much thomas soul
uh has affected me and i'm actually i'm
honored to be to be in the dock and you
use some of the footage from our
from our interview uh that we did up at
stanford
um but you know you just hit on a bunch
of the hot topic stuff
of the day and and as we're taping this
today it is uh joe biden's inauguration
but you mentioned
you talk about crime immigration urban
issues
things like that now as a wall street
journal guy my audience can probably put
together that you you lean somewhat
right
um are you hopeful are you worried
what do you feel about the incoming
administration right now
on the issues that you care about well
um i i care about uh how divided we are
as a country
right now and i'm hoping that um
joe biden can lower lower the volume a
little bit
um i think that's gotten gotten way out
of hand as we saw is what happened at
the at the capitol earlier
earlier this month uh so i'm hoping
that um that that's a priority of his
um and and and maybe maybe he'll be able
to do that he's
uh i'm encouraged uh by by some of the
things he's done so far um
some of his cabinet picks um i think
have been uh uh quite moderate in
comparison to what we could have had we
don't have a
uh uh secretary warren at treasury or
uh secretary uh bernie sanders running
the labor department
um so so i uh i am hopeful there with
some of his uh choices that he's made on
the other hand um
you know i'm quite disturbed at the
direction of the democratic party
in in recent years with the rise of the
progressives
um the uh uh you know this sort of woke
left disturbs me the black lives matter
movement types disturb me and um
the fact of the matter is that joe biden
um is the head of a party that's moved
quite a bit to the left since the last
time he was in the white house
and while he's a guy who i think has
spent a career trying to find the center
of the democratic party and
and stay right there the fact is the
party itself has moved left and so i
think we're
i fear we're going to get a lot more of
the identity politics
that we had under under president obama
and and that worries me because he left
office
with race relations in pretty pretty bad
shape i i think they continue to sour
under
under president trump but but they were
already pretty bad
when trump got into office as a result
of what happened under obama
and i'm i'm fearful that um that that
biden and his
adherence to identity politics and so
forth will
um will keep us going in that direction
unfortunately yeah are you
kind of surprised how much biden has
embraced identity politics because as
you're pointing out
he's not actually we think or at least
his history
is not one of the sort of really far
left you know the bernie elizabeth
lawrence
it is more of a centrist but it's pretty
clear that you know he's saying okay
well we got pete buddha judge so we have
a gay
transportation secretary and we got a
trans i think assistant health secretary
or deputy health secretary
nobody cares if you have gay people or
trans people and black people and all of
these things that's wonderful but
of course you want qualification are you
surprised he's doing it or do you think
do you think he's just doing a certain
amount of placating them
to to then get back to the center that
would be music to my ears but but i fear
that energy that you're talking about
yeah i think he feels he has to do it
that this is where
where the party is um and and
and if anything uh it's gotten worse
in recent years uh with i mean
think about it we we just uh celebrated
martin luther king's birthday a man who
who is associated with color blindness
judge me by the content of my character
not the color of my skin that is what
the civil rights movement used to be
about
today the civil rights movement is about
black
lives matter not all lives
black lives say it or i'm coming after
you
we've turned the king sensibility on its
head
i mean that's where we are as a country
and that's what the left is
as a country and i don't think that joe
biden feels he can
he can oppose that and succeed
politically
in the democratic party so i think he's
doing
what he feels he needs to do he needed a
he needed a black woman
as a running mate so he found a black
woman to run
um and i think he's checking off the
boxes
in terms of race and gender and sexual
orientation
right down the list because that is what
today's left demands
that's it's it's very bizarre i've asked
this of a few other people that i've had
on the show but are you
shocked at the way these these seemingly
bad ideas have taken a hold of so many
of our institutions and our political
elite and our
our media institutions and everything
else
i i am i'm i'm quite concerned um and
there's so little
so little pushback um uh there's there's
even even on the left
they're canceling each other uh if if if
if you don't toe the line
on on certain issues uh everyone from
from a stephen pinker
to an andrew sullivan to you you're not
allowed to step out of line over there
or
the mob will come after you and i find
it i find it extremely
uh disturbing um i i i don't think
that uh it's helpful in terms of
addressing real issues
in society it keeps us at each other's
throat but
um this is how uh the democratic party
wins votes this is how they gen up
their base and and and and these what
we're going
through right now with the critical race
theory i mean i'm old enough to remember
uh when this when this stuff started uh
back in the 70s and 80s in particular
but it was sort of limited to academia
and now it's spilled over into the
mainstream and we're talking about uh
you know unconscious bias and and these
ridiculous diversity training programs
and
and and demanding the self-abasement of
whites and
and to acknowledge their privilege and
all the rest this is
i think this is horrible for the country
just absolutely
horrible and and i think all of it will
be ascendant
in a joe biden presidency unfortunately
yeah i'm with you and unfortunately
is the key word there so you mentioned
just sort of generally the state of race
relations that they got worse under
obama you feel they got worse under
trump and
now here we are with with this new
ideology that seemingly will only make
it worse
when you when you say got worse what how
do you actually define that because i
find when i
the limited amount that i've traveled in
the last year because of covid but
from talking to my audience and hearing
what people are saying and when i do get
to travel
i think most people don't really care
about race i don't think people really
care about sexuality i certainly don't
think they care about gender
i think americans probably something
like 80 percent of them are kind of live
and let live they just don't know it
exactly it's not the messaging they get
how do you actually grade sort of okay
it got worse under obama or it got worse
under trump
well i'm basing that on polling data
gallup poll
asked this question every few years do
you think race relations have improved
or worsened and when obama left office
and in 2015 um
or 2016 i should say um
the the that poll answer showed that
race relations were at their lowest
point
since the early 90s so they had really
really tapered off and and they didn't
improve much
under trump at least in terms of how
people were responding
to that question now there there could
be um
uh something in the way the question is
asked or framed
or something uh and maybe anecdotally uh
it's easy uh to to counter that notion i
mean if
you know intermarriage rates are up uh
you know if things like that are going
on
if there's less segregation in in a in
in residential housing and so forth um
that would all you know point in the
opposite direction so it may be a way of
how the question is framed but i'm
basing it on the polling the polling
data that i've read
yeah and then at the same time we see
interesting things like
i think it was black female support i
think doubled for trump
uh then then four years prior we saw the
blexit movement
we did see some markers that things are
kind of changing
but i sense now it could all be for
naught
i i think we saw some some indications
that
there's no reason for the republican
party to give up on the minority vote
uh trump improved his performance
among blacks especially among hispanic
voters
and um i think that had a lot to do with
his
focus on reopening the economy uh after
covet i mean
people forget how bad things were
particularly for black
men under obama in terms of employment
the black unemployment rate
did not fall below double digits until
the seventh year
of the obama presidency so things were
very bad for a very long
time and then under trump we see record
low
unemployment rates record low poverty
rates we see the wages rising for the
least skilled workers
at the fastest rate of all workers
things were going quite well pre-coveted
in terms of the economy and and and and
kovid really shut all that down and i
think trump's focus
on reopening and getting people back to
work is one reason he improved his
numbers
uh among minorities yeah so before we
jump into
to the doc and and uh thomas so and all
that um let's do a little bit on on the
right side of things
um i think a lot of people that are
watching this probably agreeing with
your assessment of what's going on on
the left
what do you make of what's going on on
the right right now like do you think
trump
is gonna you know lead some sort of
patriot party now what happens to
establishment
republicans can they reconcile all of
this stuff
well um who knows what donald trump is
going to do
i mean i've stopped i've stopped uh
trying to guess uh about his intentions
uh it may be limited what
in what he can do depending on on how
this impeachment process
plays out i guess mitch mcconnell has
made some
some comments uh that lead some to
believe
that he would vote for conviction and
others say that if
if he does others will follow suit
and if uh the senate uh
convicts him in a way that prevents him
from running for office again then that
could
quash efforts going forward i guess he
could still have influence in terms of
of endorsing people or so forth or
funding
uh movements but um but in terms of
personally
and his own political career that could
that could probably be the uh
the nail in the in the coffin on that
yeah it does seem like
you know the quote swamp is is sort of
ready to just circle and and expunge him
but
what do you do with those 74 million
people i guess that's really the
question
well yeah he's he's he's got his
followers
uh we don't know what will happen with
them some of them were people that were
not politically active at all he made
them uh
uh come out come out and participate in
politics for the first time so
could they go back to being inactive
again um
some a lot of them and the left doesn't
like to acknowledge this but a lot of
them were former
obama voters that he won in in 2016
and me and held on to in 2020
yeah um so uh what will become of
of those voters uh without trump but you
know
yes you know the republican party is
worried about losing some of those
um some of those trump voters but i also
think and i don't know
how they compare in terms of numbers but
i can say there are also a fair number
of republicans uh
like my wife for instance who could
never bring herself to support
donald trump she didn't like the way he
talked about women or
demean the war record of military heroes
and so forth
so um she did not support republicans
while he was in office but she's
perfectly ready to go back to supporting
republican presidential candidates now
so i don't know how representative she
is
uh of of people out there so who
who knows how how this will play out um
but um i think it's clear that the
country
um may have been tired of donald trump
but
uh they they voted for divided
government they they shrunk
uh the the democrats lead in the house
uh we have a 50-50 senate
um so the country uh
is not throwing out republicanism with
with donald trump
and and i think that's something biden
should keep in mind
uh as he goes forward governing yeah if
i mean in my humble opinion if he goes
down the identity politics route that it
seems like he's going down
they're going to get crushed even harder
in two years which
probably would be good to balance things
out but well
the the i i think you know obama made
this mistake when he came into office
and maybe joe biden will learn from it
but i think um
they they saw george w bush with very
low approval ratings going out of office
and they interpreted that as a mandate
for far left agenda so they passed the
stimulus package they didn't do much
and then they turned their their their
their attention to reforming
transforming
the health care system in this country
in a highly partisan fashion
uh and it turned out to be hugely
unpopular they lost
in time both houses of congress the
democrats did and it turned it turned
out to be a disaster and it'll be
interesting to know if biden interprets
trump's unpopularity
with a mandate for moving forward with a
progressive agenda
uh i don't think people were were uh
voted for him for
a progressive agenda uh so i i i we'll
see if if
joe biden learned anything from the last
time he was in the white house yeah that
that i guess is the tension it's like
yeah he wants to or
maybe in the past would have been more
center the energy's over here and just
sort of how far can that
push and pull go all right so let's talk
about the doc and
and thomas soul first off when did you
become aware of the work of thomas seoul
how did this whole
project come together oh well well uh
i first became aware of thomas sol um
when i was in college in the early 1990s
i um
i was having something i worked for my
college paper and i was having
um a conversation about affirmative
action
uh with with one of my colleagues on the
on the school paper
and and another person walked over and
said you sound like tom saul
and i said tom who and i had no idea
who he was um person wrote down the name
of a book
uh i went and checked it out of the
school library that evening and read it
in one sitting and spent the weekend
reading everything else that the library
had by by thomas soul and i and i was
hooked
um and and so he he really had a big
impact on my sort of intellectual
development since since college um but i
was already leaning more conservative
by the time i i discover time so which
is i found out later is not at all
uncommon i mean by the time clarence
thomas discovered
uh thomas soul his reaction was well
there's someone else out there who
thinks like me
walter williams who recently passed away
had the exact same experience um
uh they were friends for 50 years and uh
but by
when they first met walter williams was
already walter williams
um so you you you hear this time and
again um
uh people have found their way to tom a
soul but he hasn't necessarily
led them to believe what what they that
what they what they what they they now
believe
right so as a guy that writing a book
about him or wrote a book about him
that's upcoming and and did the doc and
everything you must be just
like over the moon that he's had this
resurgence this renaissance oh yeah with
young people because
when i interviewed him i mean the amount
of emails that we got and handwritten
letters
and facebook messages and the whole
thing saying this man
transformed my life and and in many ways
for me you know people always say to me
dave it seems like you've changed so
much politically and i always say well
actually
i'm mostly the same economics is where i
changed
it's just that's the one like i don't i
don't deny it right
but the other stuff is pretty much there
and and was always there but economics
is the one that really changed and it
was because of thomas old it was
happening before that interview
but to me that moment that was it that
that
pretty much was it and i and i am
thrilled that a younger generation of
people
are interested in in seoul um because
what he has
written over the years is as relevant
today as ever
he was writing about social justice
issues 30 and 40 years ago
um and and and he's still right about
about these things
in fact it is amazing how long he has
been so right about so many issues
uh you can go back and read personal
letters that he wrote in the 1960s to
people
about how he thought the civil rights
movement was going to end
um it's it's it's really really amazing
um his prescience in that in that regard
but and so
in terms of of me personally uh
discovering seoul that's when it
happened back in college in terms of the
film
um uh well i guess i should start with
the book i i
i've been i've known seoul for about 15
20 years and i've been pressuring him
to let me do this biography for for some
time
and i knew i could do it without him he
said i could do it without him but i
wanted his cooperation i didn't think a
lot of
other people would talk to me um if they
if i didn't have this blessing to do it
and he finally he finally gave in and
and let me start
start writing it so i started on it
about five years ago four years ago i
got
interrupted by someone else to write
another book about another issue so i
put the
soul book aside and then i got back to
it about 2018
and then and and the result will be out
in the in the spring
uh when uh the people at the free to
choose network
and and they're the ones who produce the
documentary learned about the book
they came to me and asked me if i would
be interested in narrating a documentary
film that they were
they were putting together and saul had
a long history with the free to choose
network
through milton friedman one of his
mentors who did a series for free to
choose on public television
uh back in the early 1980s and seoul was
participated in milton friedman's show
and so they wanted to do a documentary
on seoul
they asked me if i was interested in
being a narrator and helping and
developing the film and and that's how
that that got started
yeah there's a moment i think when i was
interviewed i mentioned this moment i
don't know if it made it into the dock
but
i'm sure you'll appreciate this when uh
i finished the interview with him
and i had tweeted out right before you
know i'm about to sit down with thomas
soule
you know if he's influenced you in any
way send me a message and
maybe i can read a couple to them and i
got i mean i got hundreds if not
thousands of tweets
and i said to him at the end i said dr
solo
uh i tweeted out that you know i'm
sitting down with you and i just got
so many of these great messages if you
want to take a look and i kind of showed
him my phone
and he goes with that great voice he
goes young man
i've been doing this for a long time and
i just
i just thought it was the perfect
response like truly the perfect response
getting to what you're saying that the
things that he was talking about
30 40 years ago they're relevant and
feel new to us now
but this has been a long slog for this
guy
oh yeah yeah it it it has been and and
uh there's a there's a lot of people
think that tom is on twitter
because there's a fan fan site
and um uh it's it's run by a millennial
who's never met tom it's not an
authorized site
and all this guy does is tweet quotes
from past soul columns and books
that's it right there's no added
commentary to them he just takes these
quotes
and and tweets them out it has hundreds
of thousands of followers
which would be amazing for anyone but
especially for someone who's not on
social media like thomas solis
yeah no it really that account i mean
it's at thomas soul and for a long time
i thought it was some sort of official
account
but every time they tweet out a meme or
just a quote whatever it is and it's
like
if he wrote that yesterday you'd be
going man this guy
knows what's up and then of course you
find out oh no he wrote that
you know in 1969 or something like that
oh
people are what's amazing and that's
this this speaks to your comment about
uh how long soul has been doing this he
he you know people often say to me
uh after i give a speech or write
something in the paper
oh it you know you must be very brave to
write something like that you know if i
write
and it's really usually if i write
something contrarian about race or
or an issue like that and um uh i don't
think there's anything particularly
brave about it i think of seoul as
someone who's particularly brave i mean
he's been doing this for a long time
well before there was a fox news well
before there was social media support
or talk radio people that had his back
and that sort of thing
he was just out there writing this stuff
and he was doing it largely alone
and without the support that that many
conservatives particularly black
conservatives today have so
uh that's that's bravery in my book
what kind of support do you think black
conservatives have now because i think
you could you could probably argue it
both ways on one hand there is now some
some defense of black conservatives i
have many black conservative friends
there's
there's more out there obviously um
but on the other hand i'm not going to
have to tell you all the things that you
guys get called and
i don't even want to see him because
youtube will delete the video
that that that comes that comes with the
territory yes the name calling has
always been there but um but there's far
there's far more
support i mean i'll i'll put it this way
the way thomas put it um
uh back in the 1980s thomas soul and
walter williams made a pact
never to fly together because if the
plane went down
it would be the end of black
conservatives in america so
we're a long way from that today you
know and and
and uh just the support i get i you know
i i i was a few years ago i was invited
to speak at a
college campus and then i was disinvited
to speak
i wrote a column about it um the i went
on television and talked about it
uh the the the president of the
university was bombarded
with uh complaints from graduates
uh and and even some students at the
school for disinviting me
they reversed course and and reinvited
me
that sort of thing i i don't know that
that tom would have ever had that kind
of support
uh 30 or 40 years ago um but but that's
what's out there today
uh for for for black conservatives yeah
do you find that his
evolution as i i talked to him about and
we had this great viral clip
where i said you know how did your
political evolution happen you know he
just paused
facts you know it's just facts that's
that was what caused him to go from
you know a marxist in essence to a
libertarian um
it seems like it's happening to an awful
lot of people right now it's not
something that the media is going to
talk about but it seems like a lot of
young people are getting it
i maybe i i maybe we talk to different
young people
no a lot of them are listening too i
know that when i when i see the rise of
an
alexandria ocasio-cortez um
the way she talks about how this you
know billionaires should be banned
or or um that that sort of thing
tells me something else might be might
be going on and and
i think you know part of it might have
to do with the experience
i mean if you're a young person today
and and your idea
uh of of of how uh you know an economy
should be growing or what the employment
uh should look like in this country was
the obama years
um uh or shortly thereafter um
you know that's that's your experience
and then maybe you're you're thinking
capitalism isn't all that great of a
thing if this is
you know all it can do um so maybe you
have a skewed sense of capitalism and
maybe that's where
uh people like aoc come from in terms of
how they view
free market economics um but i i i think
that
republicans and conservative
intellectuals in general
i think need to do a better job of
communicating these ideas to young
people i think um
and in a large sense they're losing
they're losing that fight now the
young people typically are are more left
of center as tom was right when he would
jugger yeah
uh and then uh and then they grow up
they go out of it experience uh teaches
them that another way is better
um but i do think that that republicans
in particular need to do a better job of
communicating some of these ideas
ideas to young people yeah it's funny
because i hear a lot about
young people waking up to it um so that
that's my own
sort of world there but of course the
the counterbalance
is an interesting popularity basis yeah
it's been a career trying to explain
these ideas i mean his best-selling book
he's known a lot of people for his
writings on race but his
best-selling book is basic economics um
which is essentially an economics
textbook without any graphs and
equations in it
and he takes great pride in explaining
economics
uh to non-economist and everyday people
in plain english he thinks it's a
very important thing to do is one of the
things he learned from milton friedman
who spent uh his career after leaving
academia
as a public intellectual who spent a lot
of time explaining economics
to non-intellectuals on college campuses
and elsewhere
and so um uh tom has taken great pride
in doing that throughout his career and
um you know sometimes in the academy
uh that that that isn't exactly rewarded
it's looked down on
why are you writing about uh you know
for the general public instead of for
your
peers but tom uh thinks that that is a
the proper role of a public intellectual
yeah and look as we watch public
education kind of crumble it's like we
need those voices that that are going to
be willing
to do it in knowing him did you ever get
a sense
you know obviously he he wrote mostly
and cared mostly about economics but
there there's a there is a lot of racial
stuff there
do you think that that was just a
byproduct of the fact that he was black
so he kind of
was sort of pinned into it or do you
think he really wanted to talk about
that stuff
i i remember in our interview trying to
ask that question in a way that
that didn't seem pandering or something
no he
he reluctantly came to writing about
race and that's
one of the more interesting aspects of
his background
tom could have spent his career uh
writing about his first love
uh which was economics and the history
of economics and the history of ideas
that is his specialty um he was an
expert on marx
he's an expert on the classical liberals
from you know
adam smith's and john stuart mills and
so forth
that that was tom's first love writing
about those guys
and that's what he spent the beginning
of his career doing and he was good at
it
i mean he won high praise from his peers
and he could have stayed in that lane
and led a very fruitful life teaching
and writing about economics
uh he turned to writing about race as he
puts it out of a sense of duty
he said because there are things that
need to be said and
the way he put it is too many other
people have the good sense not to say
them
but they need to be said and someone's
got to do it
and and that is why he he uh turned his
attention
to race and he had a pretty formative
experience i think
when he was at cornell in the late 60s
which is when the
rioting occurred on campus and
uh he was he was there at the time he
was professor of economics at cornell
and i and i think that made quite an
impression on him
on on on on where things were headed not
just on campus
but off campus as well in terms of race
in this country
and uh i think it led ultimately to him
leaving
academia and joining uh the hoover
institution which is a think tank at
stanford
and also led to him writing more about
racial issues which is something he
turned his attention to
in the 70s and 80s do you have a sense
of how
he's feeling about the state of the
world right now i know in the last year
or so obviously because of
covet he wasn't doing many interviews we
tried to get up there and then we just
couldn't coordinate it with so many
things
he's he's 91 is that right ninety-one
nine he's nine so he's 90 years old
he'll be 91 this year in june i mean
for for 90 he is unbelievably spry and
everything else but but obviously isn't
doing as many appearances i think he was
on
i think he was on mark levin's show not
not too long ago do you get a sense of
where
he's at sort of you know in the politics
of the day
i i don't have a a good sense um
we've communicated by email a few times
uh over the past six months or so but
not not a whole lot since covid
um uh he did publish a book last year a
brand new book
on charter schools and he did some
interviews uh for that book so he's
still
working i mean he retired his column a
few years ago but he's still writing
books or
updating editions of old books and so
forth uh and i've seen him in a few
interviews you mentioned uh
the mark len show he's done some other
shows as well and i've seen some of
those interviews
but i don't get a sense of where he is
um
how he's thinking about what's going on
now i will say that um
his general uh his general default
position
is extreme pessimism
about the way the world is the way the
world is headed so i i doubt
anything that's happened in the past
year so has changed that
yeah i i have a bad feeling you're right
on that one
um how was it for you personally to to
get to know one of your heroes you know
they always say don't meet you
don't meet your heroes because it's
always going to be a letdown one way or
another
how was the whole experience for you it
was
a pure joy to spend several years
delving into
uh the intellectual life of tom soul in
his
getting inside of his head um reading uh
trying to read everything he's ever
written and he's written so much on so
many issues
and uh he's just so knowledgeable and
and and
you know he several times i found myself
well while trying to write the book um
trying to explain something more clearly
than he had already explained it
and then what he had written and and and
it was um
it was i came across that time and time
again but but it was
it was a real real thrill uh to to and i
was very happy
that he allowed me to to to do the book
or gave me the green light
it's not an authorized biography by any
sense he didn't get to see anything
uh that i'd written before it was
published but he did cooperate he did
sit for several long interviews
uh over the years and um and uh
and i was i was just very very very
grateful for
for that i i am uh
it's something i'm glad i did i i hope
uh
you know at some point i think a real
serious scholar of economics is going to
have to delve into
to tom's work uh and and really get into
the weeds which is something a little
above my pay grade because i'm just a
journalist
but um uh but i hope i produce something
that's that that's readable
i have no doubt that you have um what
about on the on the personal
side because i think sometimes you know
especially for younger people you see
these
clips on youtube of these people or you
see them in the
box on fox or cnn and you you kind of
almost don't think they're real people
like they're they're just these
these things that exist you know they're
almost like cartoon characters
of themselves in a way what did you
learn about just the way he's wired or
his
temperament or just interesting on the
on the personal side
because i don't know that people know
much much of anything
yeah i'll start with that uh
i use a story in the book to try and
explain uh tom's personality and i use a
joke
um from an old movie there's a there's
an old movie called sabrina
uh starring harrison ford that came out
i think in the 90s sometime
and um uh and and the law of interest
in the movie um
is uh harrison ford plays this very
curmudgeonly
industrialist and uh the
the family has a long time chauffeur and
the daughter of the chauffeur falls for
for harrison ford's character and she
goes to her dad's son one day and she
says
dad what was harrison ford like when he
was when he was younger
and her father looks at her and says
shorter
i think i got the idea and uh
it's a way of just saying tom soul has
been tomsol for a very very very long
time and if you go back and read
or talk to him about um you know
arguments he would have
for people when he was in grade school
or high school
um very much like uh the arguments he
has with people today he's
he's someone who has been um uh
sort of uh ready for intellectual combat
it seems like since the day he was born
he
is very serious person he doesn't suffer
fools
but he's also a very generous person a
very kind
person and i got that from a lot of
a lot of people i interviewed tom would
go to bat with them but they came to him
with a problem with it whether it was a
colleague
a student someone like that tom was
willing to go to bat for them
and uh so that side of him also also
came through
but um but he's always been a you know a
a very
um uh intellectually curious person
and and someone who um um
was pretty confident of his of his
abilities um
uh and you know he's a former marine
uh which might surprise a lot of people
because he's also a bit of a loner
he's not much of a team player and i
don't think those those attributes work
very well in the middle
in the military and i know for a fact
he made it through i know for a fact
he's not much of a techie because we
were trying to get
skype on his computer so we could do it
during covid
but he didn't want it he didn't want to
download it and then we were going to
literally deliver a computer to his door
that he would have just had to open
but the whole whole other situation you
you know one of the other
he's he's not a people a people person
and
in that sense he's he's worked from home
for a long
a long time he has an office uh on the
stanford campus but
um generally he he would go in just to
do interviews with people
uh but mostly work from home yeah you
know it's so interesting because right
now when we all talk about the sort of
lack of discourse and the lack of sort
of honest public debate and it was like
for years he was debating all sorts of
people on firing line all these other
shows and and public events and all of
that and i would guess
that if they're you know i'm sure he
loves the writing that he's still doing
but i'm guessing he misses probably some
some level of that the the public
sparring with some of the people
um i guess so but you know like he said
he's 90 years old he's been doing it for
a long time
um i think he's set his piece uh more
than
more than a few dozen times knockout he
doesn't need that last round
yeah you know i i i remember asking him
after he retired the column
uh we were having dinner and i said um
uh do you miss being able to get things
off your chest and he said no there's
nothing left on my on my chest
i i think he you know
seoul put a lot of thought and time into
into
his work and um uh
and and that required you know doing
your homework and staying up on current
events and so forth
and i think not having to do that
anymore i mean he mentioned
uh right before he retired his column or
decided to retire it that he had gone on
a
sort of photo safari with a group of
fans he's he's an amateur
photographer and a very good one and has
been for a long time and he and a few
buddies went on a
on a photo outing uh a multiple day one
and they you know they didn't have any
access to radio or tv for a few days and
um
he recalled how pleasant that experience
was and you know he's already well into
his 80s and he said you know
i think i'm ready to tune out of the
day-to-day
um and so i i think he's he's probably
enjoying it i mean like
like i said he's still doing the books
and and staying active intellectually
on that front but i don't think he
misses probably churning out that uh
that column or two everywhere yeah
you'll probably appreciate this when
when we sat down at stanford his guys
said he's got 45 minutes like he doesn't
want to sit there for makeup it's like
when he gets in
sit down start 45 minutes so i was very
aware
i did not want to take one extra minute
of his time and when we hit 45 i ended
it
and he looked at me the second the
camera went off and he goes is that all
like i think he said i think he said is
that all we we just started or something
to that effect and i thought
man if i would have known that i
i would have kept going but i wanted to
be respectful of you know
that he's busy and all of those things
uh well listen i i am super psyched
obviously to watch the doc and i'm
honored to be part of it
and uh and i can't wait to get the book
as well is there anything else that
that you'd want people to know before
they partake in the doc
or or pick up the book
no i i think you've covered it i think
it
i think both the book and the
documentary is a nice introduction
to thomas soul and then i i hope people
i hope i wet their appetite
and they go read more of them um because
like i said
and like you like you said um he's been
right for a long time and his stuff is
as relevant today
as it's ever been so um so we'll see
what happens awesome well jason i'm glad
we finally
got to talk and uh should we should we
send people to your twitter
should we send them to your twitter oh
that's fine
twitter riley no there's a letter in
there somewhere right it's it's
it's at jason reilly w s j s j that's it
okay i knew it was in there somewhere
all right well it was a pleasure to have
you on i can't wait to see the doc and
i'll talk to you soon
take care if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell